hi
my name is jeff sisson and i work at the
new york times as part of a team
that builds the tools the new newsroom
uses to publish our journalism
i hope to describe how our team uses
open source technologies
and firestore to create a completely
unique rich text editor for the new york
times
but first i want to describe a radical
position i've come to believe as a
byproduct of our work
on tools for the newsroom hear me out
everyone deserves their own
collaborative rich text
editor so let me explain what i mean
here
rich text editors like google docs have
made what you see is what you get style
editing a seamless experience
this actually makes it harder to
appreciate some of the complexity that
underlies a pleasant rich text
editor most people just want it to work
they want to work
in an editor that produces html like
documents
which may include bold italics
strikethrough
other emphasis and they want to compose
using paragraph
lists possibly even tables or images or
other more complex layouts
even when just editing plain text there
are lots of subtleties that
editors like google docs or word handle
for you
there's live as you type text
suggestions for grammar or spelling
errors
or the ability for others to comment on
the document or
tracking the changes that you've made to
a document over time
and it's now even a common assumption
that if you're editing a rich text
document in a browser it must be
networked
meaning anyone can view the changes as
you're making them and contribute their
own changes
live so all of this is obviously a lot
it's reasonable to wonder why anyone
would want to create their own rich
text editor that does all of these
things rather than relying
on one of the many capable text editors
that exist
like google docs or word or even tools
like medium or wordpress
a little bit more detail on our work at
the new york times where
the tools that we maintain for editors
producers and reporters
facilitate publishing articles in our
coverage of the news
so the new york times has a huge
newsroom at any time of day
someone is working to report on world
events in articles that are often
published while that news is still
happening
we've had a number of different cmss
over the years and when we set out to
build a new article editor
we knew that we wanted it to be
collaborative first photo editors should
be able to
place photos while other editors are
polishing a draft of the text
ready to publish and yet other editors
may be readying new quotes or new
information for later publishing
and all of this needs to be happening
for users that are located in bureaus
around the globe
split amongst many different time zones
enter oak so what is oak oak is the name
of the rich text editor we built that
powers every article published by the
new york times
what are we looking at in this
screenshot uh in the white canvas in the
center
you can see that the basic skeleton of
an empty new york times article
exists you have a headline a summary
some bylines
and a time stamp below that we have
placeholder text that
commands you to begin writing uh where
the innards of the article go
so things like paragraphs images videos
interactive graphics
diptychs scrolling text and image
combinations contributor bylines and
much much more
this is the basic canvas for oaks rich
text blocks
and to the left of that canvas there are
extra textual
tools like spell check and validation
for new york times specific writing
rules
and a space for writing drafts all of
these things together
are workflow tools that are specifically
tuned to how the new york times
newsroom works and very few of these
features exist
in other off-the-re off-the-rack
rich text editors
so why did we build oak from scratch
rather than building something on top of
a different proprietary editor
the new york times has a specific
editorial process that
is very unique to itself we use a style
guide that governs how articles are
written
there are rules for how obituary
headlines are written
rules for the use of courtesy titles
such as mr and miz
and rules for the use of datelines like
washington
and all caps at the top of an article to
indicate that a reporter was actually
working from a specific location
these editorial nuances are part of what
contributes to the times's unique voice
and building our own editor allowed us
to incorporate these rules into how the
editor works
so that the newsroom can see feedback
for an article as it's being written and
edited
before it's published reporters may
contribute a first draft of an article
then hand off to a first editor who may
work with the second editor
or copy editor some highly sensitive
articles are even
edited uh in with a privacy mode so that
only parts of the newsroom that are
working on them
can see the articles prior to
publication all of these
rules for around who can access a story
and edit it at different parts of an
article's editorial life cycle
were only able to be built into oak
because we were building an editor from
scratch and our editor also aims for
what you see is what you mean fidelity
and what does that mean so
when editors are working in the oak
article editor all the styles for
headlines
paragraphs and other elements that you
see as a reader are also shown to them
meaning that the newsroom has instant
feedback on exactly how their story will
look when it's published
many rich text editors are focused
primarily on the editing
and so this ability to sort of see the
shape of the article
as it's being written has helped to
change the kinds of articles that we
publish
all of these features together are
difficult to achieve in off-the-rack
rich text editors which is part of why
most evoke was built from scratch to
accommodate our newsroom's needs
we want our reporters editors and
producers to focus
on contributing journalism and let the
rich text editor itself
do much of the heavy lifting around
editorial workflow and document
production
but we didn't attempt to build our
editor alone
the main technical component that allows
the new york times and of course you if
you want to create the rich text editor
of our dreams is called prose mirror
it's a set of open source javascript
libraries developed by marine haverbeck
that do the hard parts of rich text
editing in web browsers
the browser technology that most rich
text editors rely on
is something called content editable and
as a software spec
it's actually very messy and
inconsistent how input events like
pastes
key presses and selections are
interpreted very wildly between
different browsers and there are many
long-standing bugs and gotchas
even on modern browsers like google
chrome froze mirror abstracts around
many of these inconsistencies
which allows developers to work with
straightforward primitives
you have a document that's represented
by a node a selection that uses a
selection class
and changes to a document are
represented by transforms
and transactions prosmer also handles
painting some of these updates to a rich
text document
into the dom when a document changes
whether that document is changed by text
that you've typed into it
or via a remote collaborating peer pros
mirror will make sure the dom reflects
the latest state of the document
in pros mirror everything is a node even
the top level document
each top level document node contains
one or more children
each of which may contain their own
children and have attributes
this document here on screen represents
a very simple paragraph with the
the text hello world bolded and
italicized
but documents of course can be much more
complex so
every article in the new york times
publishes contains many types of
different nodes
and the purpose of the oak editor is to
allow editors in the newsroom the
flexibility to produce
new combinations of nodes that may share
some of the same
node patterns with other articles but
may use different types of nodes or
different orders if nodes
emphasize a particular structure of a
story within an article
here you can see what our readers would
see for an article that was created in
oak and appears on our website about
pollution in china and here's that same
article as it appears in the oak editor
along with a view of the node data
structure that underlies
the article all of the rules for what
types of document can contain
and their order live in something called
a schema definition
that prosemirror understands and is able
to enforce
as you make changes to the document so
whenever i'm reading a new york times
article i often think about it
and it's underlying node structure and
schema with a sort of x-ray view in my
head
this article about curving pollution
starts with a header and the header
contains itself a headline summary elite
media node and a byline node and then
the header is followed by a paragraph
that contains text itself contains a
link and so on and so
forth so
pros mirror schema allows you to impose
really far-fetched constraints on your
document shape
it has its own language which is a
subset of regex
that can mandate complex rules of
adjacency for different types of nodes
or constrain how many nodes of a
specific type can be added in a specific
position or in a row
this fine grained control over what is
valid for a rich text document
unlocks many fascinating opportunities
for creating rich text editors
with experiences that are tuned to
different kinds of documents
that they were built for so just to take
some examples
you might have a hiku editor that has
live feedback as you're typing about the
number of syllables
per line and constrains the lines as you
type them
or an ulipo editor where two people are
working on the same document at the same
time
but only see a shared strand of text
between them so they compose stories
as part of one holistic whole or maybe
you'd have a highly
highly structured faq editor that offers
suggestions about the types of headings
as you type them
or an email editor that intersperses
emoji or color as you're writing them
with frozmir the different kinds of
schemas that you can produce
are really unlimited which is extremely
powerful
with the schema in place for your
document it's time to start editing
every change to a document whether it's
typing text into a paragraph
dragging or dropping an image or
italicizing existing text
produces a data structure in prose
mirror that's called a step
the basic recipe for how you go from one
document state to the next document
state is by adding a step to it
steps are created from an existing
document and refer to an indexing system
whereby each letter
or leaf node within a document can be
addressed with a number
so in our example hello world doc the h
in hello is at index
2 and similarly the d in world starts at
index 12.
so if i was to type an exclamation point
into a prose mirror managed editor with
this document in it
the exclamation point would be
represented as a replace step which is a
specific class of step
at position 12 containing a string
which contains the exclamation point
prosmeir's collaborative plugin tracks
the local state of the document
using a monotonic counter that starts at
zero so
if you have an empty document you have a
document with a step counter of zero
for each step produced in the local
document the counter increments by one
once the step is created the prismir
collaborative plugin requires you to
implement what's called
an authority server in order for that
step to be synced remotely
the authority server's job is either to
accept or reject incoming steps from
multiple clients
according to whether those clients are
attempting to insert steps in
or out of order clients whose steps are
acknowledged by the authority's server
continue on their merry way clients
whose steps are rejected because their
steps were submitted out of order and
don't reflect their other peers steps
need to perform an operation that
basically operates like a git rebase
the prosmero collaborative plugin will
take into account
any steps that the local client hasn't
yet fetched
and change the steps to reflect those
other peers steps once this rebase
operation is complete
the client can attempt to resend their
steps back to the authority server
so while pros mirror collaborative
editing architecture requires a central
authority server in order to
order incoming steps from all connected
clients
it actually only provides a reference
implementation which means you're on the
hook to provide your own implementation
this reference implementation is only
persisted in memory
and can't really scale and so when we
set out to build collaborative editing
in oak
we knew we needed to build an authority
server we evaluated several different
databases and back-end architectures to
support collaborative editing
but ultimately we settled on firestore
part of firestore's appeal is that in
addition to providing traditional
database functionality so
acid reads and writes it also comes with
a client compatible event bus built in
for oak which is a browser-based
application this means that we're able
to read and write changes from the
database directly in the browser
oak uses redux and redux saga to manage
its local state
and because firestore is an event bus as
well we can treat firestore as if it was
just another local to the browser event
sync
steps arrive from firestore and are
wrapped in redux actions that mutate the
local state
this vastly simplified the architecture
we needed to build our editor
we didn't need to build out a crud api
an event bus
and all of the client-side adapter code
you'd need to integrate with a custom
backend
in the oak editor each time a pros
mirror instance produces a new step
we serialize that steps data to json and
attempt to write that step to firestore
using the latest known step id
plus one as the firestore document key
for an empty document starting at step
id 0 we would attempt to write our first
step with a firestore key of one
and for the second step we would attempt
to write with a firestore key of 2
and so on if a firestore document exists
with the next
most step id key we end the transaction
this signals to our client code that we
need to rebase our local steps to
reflect steps we haven't yet fetched
from firestore
before attempting to resend our local
steps again
but if the insert succeeds our firestore
listener will see the steps as they're
inserted and we will locally use this to
confirm them
so that subsequent steps use the new
document state and step id
as the starting point
when reading steps whether you're
confirming a step you yourself inserted
or
receiving a step from another
collaborator the implementation looks
exactly the same
firestore collection listener when the
steps collection is updated we fetch any
steps greater
than the last step id and apply them to
the local state of the document
because the listener executes whether or
not the steps you're attempting to
insert
have been successful
rebasing other client steps are handled
using this same listener as well
the firestore listener acts like an
event stream for any step that's been
confirmed remotely by firestore whether
those steps are your own or someone
else's
and here i have a demo of
the oak editor that's been modified to
sort of show this
process uh in action this is a
simplified version of the yoke article
editor
normally firestore's apis are nearly
instantaneous
so i've changed it so that calls to
firestore are artificially slower than
they would be in real life to make it
easier to see what's going on
i've also added this text at the top
here that illustrates communication with
firestore under the hood and i've hidden
other parts of the app as well set up
two tabs one on the left and one on the
right that are connected to the same oak
article that was just created
meaning this step counter here starts at
zero
when i type the word hello in the
headline the left tab
a redux saga detects that there are
steps that haven't been sent and
attempts to send them with a firestore
transaction
one for each letter once the firestore
transaction completes
the firestore collection listener in the
right tab detects the latest steps and
applies them to the document
bringing the steps collection up to five
steps stored
because this editor has been
artificially slowed down we can actually
simulate the case where both tabs
attempt to execute a firestore
transaction at the same time
i'll type the word world in the left tab
and high
in the right tab the left tab will win
which causes the right tab
to detect a conflict and rebase its
steps
after that it re-attempts a transaction
inserting its steps bringing both tabs
up to sync with each other
oak articles of course are not just
limited to text
because every change is a step even
pasting something like a link to an
embedded tweet
is modeled as a step that will be sent
to and stored in firestore and synced
with both tabs
so pros mirror itself doesn't mandate
how collaborative editing is implemented
and you're free to choose whichever
backend suits your needs
firestore was a good fit for the new
york times because we needed to build a
collaborative editor really quickly
without worrying too much about how the
back end would scale
while our daily number of articles in
production is relatively modest
the true scale for our collaborative app
is determined by the rate at which p
most people can type which can add up
quickly choosing firestore allowed us to
not worry about whether or not our
database would handle
our anticipated load i think firestore
is also a good fit for anyone
building collaborative editing that's
part of a broader client said heavy
browser app
it's really freeing to think of
firestore as just another event source
within your browser-based app where
mutations to your app state may come
from
remote changes or local changes and you
can focus your
client code on what those mutations are
doing rather than how they're produced
finally firestore allowed us to simplify
our overall
architecture we didn't need to build out
a credit api
or worry about back-end race conditions
we were mostly able to focus on
our app's business logic i hope
everyone is sufficiently enthralled and
inspired to build a
million tiny beautiful collaborative
rich text editors for whatever purposes
suit your whims or fancy
i want to give a shout out to the oak
and publishing teams
at the new york times i have to say that
the project of
building a collaborative editor was
truly a multi-year collaborative effort
in its own right
and i'm proud of the work we all jammed
on together thank you
and go build the rich text editor of
your dreams
you